i am taking the term [ __ ] and turning
it around it is not a derogatory term it
is something that i'm proud of and it
means that i've done something right
because i'm memorable
hi i'm christine quinn and this is
glamour unfiltered
i wish i could say that confidence was
something that i was born with it's
something that i've acquired over the
years and really learned along the way
i you know came from a very small town
and i was told no and i was told that
things weren't possible but i knew
inside that i had fire and ambition so i
used people's doubt as
power and fire and intuition um so every
time i was told no it made me push
harder and harder
i think
we are only in competition with
ourselves the thing that we don't
realize is as human beings we're capable
of everything and anything it's really
important to never compare yourself to
other people because you're so special
and you're so individual and i know it's
so hard you know i live in a city of
beautiful women walking down the street
every day and it's so hard i see them
and you know i'm like gosh why don't i
look like this why like why you know but
then what i do is i turn my brain and i
say you know what i'm so grateful that
i'm so intelligent i have a loving
family i have you know a beautiful son
and i think about all the things that
i'm grateful for and i think it's really
important to retrain your brain
i came out um probably a year and a half
ago and i said that i suffered from
anxiety and depression and it was
something that i was ashamed of for
years i never wanted to tell anyone but
i got help and you know i worked with a
therapist and i um it changed my life
it's one of those things that
as long as you recognize it then you're
able to help yourself and since then
i've found really great tricks
journaling for me is something i do
every night and it's very
meditative and refreshing i will write a
list of 10 things a day minimum that i'm
grateful for because i think it's really
important
to stay grounded and realize how special
you really are when we're in a whole
entire world of people you know that
sometimes try to bring you down
i signed up for social media when i was
29 years old the show just came out and
i never had facebook i never had twitter
i never had instagram i never had any
social platform
so for me you know i went into it with a
really positive attitude however um
that was the first time i experienced
hate
and hateful comments from people you
know that didn't even know me and it was
it was a shock at first it was really
really difficult i remember many nights
crying just wishing i was dead from all
these horrible comments and letters and
threats death threats you know on me and
my family then i realized this is my
chance to
let people in to have them know me for
the real me so i started building my
social media and i started engaging with
fans and people i'd never met before and
doing videos and stories and showing off
my goofy self and through that i have
created
um an incredible fan base of people that
are like-minded you know people that are
on my same level people that are
supportive of other women it's just a
great place for women to lift each other
up
i feel most empowered when i'm around
like-minded women and i think that's the
most important thing is women have to
stick together
and um
i i just i i think it's my life mantra
i would say i'm absolutely a feminist
it's something that you know has been
important to me from day one and i grew
up in
dallas texas and where i grew up you
know chivalry was
you know the women would stay at home
and the men would work and i knew i
wasn't cut out for that so i'm really
happy to be a woman in the workforce and
all the people that work with me are all
women you know from my literary agents
to my my publicist to
people i employ and i love that
i am taking the term [ __ ] and turning
it around it is not a derogatory term
it is something that i'm proud of and it
means that i've done something right
because i'm memorable well-behaved women
never make history and for me you know
when the show came out people were like
oh you're such a [ __ ] you're such a
[ __ ] you're such a [ __ ] you're talking
about me you remember me you know i i
caused a kerfuffle and i think that's
the one thing
that is important especially in business
you know you want to be remembered so
i've reclaimed that word you know it's
the name of my book how to be a boss
fitch so it's something that's near and
dear to my heart
women you know we have many different
sides for the collection we decided to
do a sweet and sassy and with that came
a lip cream that is a patented formula
that transforms with heat and changes
colors from hot to cold so you're really
able to achieve
a beautiful glam daytime look or amp it
up for a nighttime look
i never knew what i wanted to do when i
was a little girl i didn't know i wanted
to be an actress or a model but i always
knew i wanted to entertain and i always
wanted to make people feel something so
that was my goal with the show and um
you know i wouldn't necessarily say i
play a character but you know like many
women i'm you know very versatile but
yes you know there is two sides because
yes i am the villain and i'm really
strong i'm really powerful i'm really
outspoken
i'm known for my honesty but also you
know i have a really kind sweet
loving generous side
appearing on television didn't really
alter the way that i perceived myself
the hardest part was you know people
giving advice and they always do and
they say oh you know well don't dress
this way don't wear that you know don't
be so loud you know don't have so many
opinions it was other people trying to
tell me who to be trying to fit me in a
box in a mold and i'm meant to be an out
of the box thinker
oh my gosh christine at home
i you know wear baggy sweats and
disheveled hair i never wear makeup when
i'm not working ever ever ever ever i
actually enjoy the time
that i'm not glam i like to give my skin
a break and i actually i'm quite a
tomboy believe it or not
motherhood has been fantastic i never
thought that i could love someone as
much as i love myself but i do um i have
a four-month-old boy and he is just
beautiful he's the love of my life
there's a point where i was like i don't
know if i can do this you know i don't
know if i can do it all but i learned to
alter my schedule and um it's the best
thing ever i i love being able to do it
all and he really really changed my life
he was a miracle baby and i had a really
really traumatic birth and you'll see
that play out on season four but i
immediately went into surgery um i was
it was insane um i was flatlining my
baby was flatlining they kept coming up
to my husband and asking
you need to choose one right now
because you know the baby was stable i
wasn't stable was going back and forth
and he said i'm not choosing one i need
you to have both
eventually 22 minutes later from the
time i walked in the hospital to the
time i had the baby my baby was born and
we were both okay
but it was a really traumatic experience
and that taught me that time is all we
have and time is so precious and at 33
years old i almost died
so um when they were closing me up
they were in such a hurry because i was
losing so much blood
they had to just sew me up and they were
afraid that they left tools in me so
they had to put me through an x-ray
machine
um it was very traumatic so now i i
don't sweat the small things anymore you
know because i realize that every day is
um something that we should be grateful
for you know and i never would have
thought at 33 that i would go through
something like that you know it's just
something you don't think about but it
really changed me and it taught me to
value you know not only time but the
people that are around you
you